in 2018 president donald trump was at
the united nations and he issued a stark
warning to the german delegation he said
if you continue on the path that you are
going down you will one day become
dependent on russian oil at the time
there's video of the germans literally
laughing at the president of the united
states there were media outlets that
claimed that president trump's
statements were outrageous here's the
video
[Music]
germany will become totally dependent
on russian energy
if it does not immediately change course
[Music]
here in the western hemisphere
we are committed
to maintaining our independence
from the
encroachment
of expansionist foreign powers
[Music]
now remember this video is from 2018. if
you fast forward to 2022 all of that
came true germany is on its knees
begging russia and other oil exporters
around the world to help solve their
problem we have seen the price of oil
spike to more than 130 dollars a barrel
and germany is experiencing an energy
crisis this energy crisis is not
exclusive to that country it is rolling
throughout all of europe and with winter
approaching there is a great cause for
concern the average family will not be
able to afford their electricity bill
and there is likely to be stark amounts
of hunger
and freezing the country of russia
played the world they played a game of
chess
and they sure as hell have come pretty
close to checkmate they are pulling in
more revenue from their oil than they
ever have before according to the deputy
chief economist at the institute of
international finance russia is swimming
in cash the country has made just under
a hundred billion dollars from oil and
gas sales through july of this year and
as sergey vokalinko pointed out
nobody is brave enough to sanction
7.5 million barrels of russian oil
russia played the world and now they are
pulling in historic profits the pursuit
of energy independence for various
countries around the world is now a
national security issue we must not
allow countries to pursue the esg
movement as a form of virtue signaling
when it flies in the face of common
sense the importance of energy
independence has never been more obvious
if a country wants to remain sovereign
if they want to lessen their dependency
on russia or other countries that may
become adversarial to their national
interest
they must pursue energy independence
today
is a new day
the decisions of the past cannot be
changed but what we do know is that
those comments in 2018 which were
laughed at at the time they became true
and now we must deal with the
consequences hey you did you like this
video great make sure you subscribe like
the video and see you next time